- [Instructor] I wanna
do a quick clarification
on the video on alcohols.
In that video, I gave this example
of this alkanol right over here,
it has a triple bond between
the five and six carbons.
And I just wanna clarify that in reality,
it would not ever be drawn this way.
That this was an error to
actually draw it this way.
The way I should have drawn
it is this right over here.
And you see, the only difference
between these two pictures,
starting with the one carbon, two carbon,
three carbon, everything looks the same.
Four carbon attached
to the hydroxyl group,
everything looks the same.
And then we get to the five carbon,
but instead of bending back up,
we just keep going
straight to the six carbon,
that's where we have the triple bond
between the five and six carbon,
and then we go straight
again to the seven carbon
that's attached to the two bromo groups.
And then we get to the eighth carbon.
And the whole point why
this right over here,
that this is the correct way to draw it,
the correct way to draw it,
is that triple bonds,
this triple bond right here,
it forces a linear configuration.
So on both sides of that triple bond,
you would go straight out.
So whenever you see an,
actually, whenever you see
any type of an alkyne drawn,
the triple bonds should
essentially straighten out.
It should straighten out the molecule.